Mr Khan thank you
years ago
U.N members agreed solemn principles in
the UN Charter vital for International
Peace and security
they undertook to refrain from the
threat or the use of force against the
territorial integrity
or the political independence of any
state
yet seven months ago President Putin
invaded Ukraine illegally
and without justification
he ignored the resounding pleas for
peace that I heard in this Council on
the 17th of February
since then Ukrainian Spirit of defense
and Defiance in the protection of their
country continues to inspire free
people's
and Nations
every day
devastating consequences of Russia's
Invasion become more clear
un agencies have confirmed more than 14
000 civilian casualties so far and the
actual total is likely to be much higher
more than 17 million ukrainians in
humanitarian need 7 million displaced
within Ukraine and more than 7 million
Ukrainian refugees in Europe
we see the mounting evidence of Russian
atrocities against civilians including
indiscriminate shelling and targeted
attacks on over 200 medical facilities
and 40 educational institutions and
horrific acts of sexual violence
we see from the reports of the office of
the High Commissioner for human rights
that in parts of Ukraine currently under
Russian control civilians are subject to
torture
arbitrary detention and forced
deportation to Russia
and we have seen more grisly discoveries
in Islam
and it's not just ukrainians who are the
victims
President Putin's War has spread
hardship and food insecurity across the
globe plunging millions of the world's
most vulnerable
into hunger
and famine
and once again as we've seen here today
Russia has sought to deny responsibility
it's tried to lay the blame on those who
have rightly imposed sanctions on
President Putin's regime in response to
his illegal actions
us be clear we are not sanctioning food
it is Russia's actions that are
preventing food and fertilizer getting
to developing countries it is Russia's
tactics and bombs that are to blame for
destroying Ukraine's Farms
infrastructure and delaying its exports
I sat here in February
listening to the Russian representative
assuring this Council
that Russia had no intention of invading
its neighbor
we now know that was a lie
and today I have listened to further
installments of Russia's catalogs of
distortions
dishonesty and disinformation
he has left the chamber
I'm not surprised I don't think Mr
lavrov wants to hear
the collective condemnation of this
Council but we saw through him then and
we saw through him again today
we have information
which means that we know
that Russia is about to hold sham
referenda on Sovereign Ukrainian
territory
with no basis in law
under the threat of violence after mass
displacements of people in areas that
voted overwhelmingly
for Ukrainian Independence
we know what Vladimir Putin is doing
he is planning to fabricate the outcome
of those referenda
he is planning to use that to Annex
Sovereign Ukrainian territory
and he is planning to use it as a
further pretext
to escalate his aggression that is what
he plans to do
and we call on all countries to reject
the charade
and to refuse to recognize any results
we are used to seeing Russian lies and
distortions
but
let us listen to the testimony of
ukrainians who tell us the truth
who tell us the reality
or President Putin's War
Dr Elena usvak
her husband
Ole
and their 22 year old son dimitro
were abducted by Russian forces from
their home in Hostel
near Buca in March
Russian soldiers shot Olay twice in the
legs
before they were all blindfolded and
bundled into an armored personnel
carrier and I want you to hear only a
story in her own words and I quote
first they took us to a bombed out house
the Russian soldiers kept saying they
were going to kill us my husband was
left for hours lying on the floor in the
pool of his blood
I don't know why
we'd done nothing wrong
then they took my son away from us I
don't know where I don't know if we'll
ever see him again I just want my boy
back
end of quote
Elena's story and those are many others
tell us the truth the real truth this is
a war of annexation a war of Conquest to
which President Putin now wants to send
even more of Russia's young men and
women making peace even less like less
likely
Mr Putin must understand the world is
watching and we will not give up
members of the security Council we must
unequivocally reject Russia's attempts
to Annex Ukrainian territory we must
make clear to President Putin that his
attack on the Ukrainian people must stop
that there can be no impunity for those
perpetrating atrocities
and that he must withdraw from Ukraine
and restore Regional and global
stability
if he chose to he could stop this war
a war which has done Untold damage to
the Ukrainian and the Russian peoples
his war is an assault on Ukraine
an assault on the U.N Charter and an
assault on the international Norms that
protect us all so
we stand with our Ukrainian friends for
as long as it takes
because Ukraine's Fight For Freedom is
the world's Fight For Freedom it is our
fight for freedom and if Ukraine's
sovereignty
and territory are not respected
then no country is truly secure these
are the reasons why Ukraine can and must
win thank you